la russie à la france faisant tous deux
partie du groupe de minsk au sein de
l'eau et c'est eux il était donc tout à
fait naturel que les deux chefs d'état
s'entretiendront sujet de la question du
haut karabagh une situation dans le
haut-karabagh qui s'est grandement
améliorée disons le après six semaines
de conflit intenses entre les forces
arméniennes et azéri qui ont fait
plusieurs milliers de morts emmanuel
macron et vladimir poutine se sont mis
d'accord sur la nécessité de poursuivre
la résolution des problèmes humanitaires
pressants notamment le retour des
réfugiés par le corridor de latchine la
principale route d'accès à s'était pas
dunkerque est actuellement fermé car les
forces russes du maintien de la paix y
effectue un travail minutieux de
nettoyage de ramassage des corps et de
déminage afin que les réfugiés puissent
d'ici quelques jours emprunter de
nouveau c'est route pour regagner leur
maison la seule route actuellement qui
permet d'accéder à stepanakert celle que
nous avons dû emprunter en faisant un
détour de plus de six heures et celle
qui passe par le village de quel jabbar
au nord c'est ce village où il ya encore
quelques jours des arméniens préféré
brûlé leurs maisons plutôt que de les
abandonner aux azéri et c'est à
proximité de ce village aussi que se
trouve l'église orthodoxe de daddy vente
une église au coeur des discussions
concernant l'aspect religieux de ce
conflit en effet bien que le président
azéri ilham alief est assurée à vladimir
poutine que les sites religieux
arméniens serait sous protection et que
les arméniens du haut karabagh pourrait
continuer de s'y rendre
dans la réalité la situation risque
d'être plus compliqué on sait que de
nombreux sites religieux arméniens ont
subi d'importantes dégradations de la
part de l'armée azerbaïdjanaise alors
les deux communautés
vont-elles pouvoir cohabiter dans le
futur le porte-parole des forces russes
de maintien de la paix a déclaré étudier
de manière approfondie la question de la
fréquentation des lieux de culte ce qui
est sûr en tout cas c'est que la
présence des forces de maintien de la
paix fait beaucoup de bien aux habitants
du haut karabagh à stepanakert la vie
reprend doucement son cours
l'électricité revient peu à peu et les
commerces se mettent à réouvrir jour
après jour